please welcome oliver hudson
hello i was listening to you on stern
i was i pulled up into my driveway and i
stayed in my driveway for
i don't know 35 minutes just to hear you
so i just wanted to tell you how much i
loved your interview
i'm i'm so relieved to hear you say that
because
i tried to listen to it and i was like
this is so long i can't i don't listen
to myself anymore so
that's a much nicer uh commentary than
my inner voice and thank you for saying
that and
i was listening you know to your podcast
about
fatherhood and what was your intention
behind doing this successful podcast
well first of all joe and i have been
friends for a long time we're sort of
unlikely
friends no one would think that we are
joe you know his
top priority in his life is being a
father he has
girls who are 20 in their 20s and now he
has new twins
my number one priority in my life is
being a dad
above career above most anything right
um it's our legacy it's what we leave
here
really you know and um i just thought it
was an underexplored
place and we get real and we talk
you know real stuff we don't hold back
much
and it's unafraid and we get to
interview really great people and
hear about what it was like growing up
and how they
father themselves or parent themselves
and it's been fulfilling it's been
awesome it's just
it's been really really fun for me
you've had extraordinary guests
allah alex rodriguez adam sandler mark
cuban the list is very long
and eddie vetter vetter was great i
cried at the end i mean he was lit
he's like you know i love you man i'm
like i love you too eddie
i was like you know cause i was talking
about my own father and that situation
and it was he was he's an amazing dude
well one of the things that really
struck me
when i was doing the research on this
was
your relationship with your dad
and i got very personally invested
[Music]
your dad with goldie hawn my mama
that's right the person everybody wants
to be their mom or their best friend or
their sister
i mean i know it's it's funny because
when i was a kid i just railed against
it i didn't want
anyone to know who my parents were i
wanted to survive
on my own merit but as i've gotten older
pride has kicked in
and um yeah i'm proud of of who my
mother is who my family is
you know i mean damn you just want to
have your own identity
i think but what i really got struck by
was i felt a very personal connection
with you
because you were talking about your dad
and how you were close with him and at a
certain point
you guys uh became sort of estranged if
you will
yeah and the thing that really knocked
me off my socks was that
he and his dad had had a similar journey
yeah my dad and i have a our we have a
relationship now for the first time in a
long time
and it was it was spurned on by my in
dark sort of insane sense of humor you
know i
wrote i instagramed and i said happy
abandonment day
and i was just trying to be funny it
blew up
long story short it brought us together
because it created a dialogue
you know um but yes so i've done a lot
of work on myself
i went to this place called the hoffman
institute which was incredible for me
um where i learned forgiveness and
compassion true forgiveness true
compassion and what that really means
i went and looked into his life a little
bit more and understood where he came
from
so it's there's been a catharsis that
i've had
we have a really great relationship now
and um
it's just interesting how life plays out
and how things work
first of all the sense of humor with
that post and your dad
i think humor does save us and my mom
was the same
her family was not there
and she was estranged and then we
repeated that pattern
and i think that due to my own
experiences
and my mom's experience i was like i
have to get this
different i it's not right or wrong but
i'm gonna have a determination about
this that may have not been there
otherwise and i'm so grateful for it and
my mom and i
are good now too it's like
there's just some peace and respect and
maturity there that could not have taken
place maybe before
timing is everything and i'm just so
entranced and enthralled by your journey
and the fact that you're
sharing it everyone has has a story to
tell you know the
the parents it's a tough thing you know
i mean
you you're going through it listening to
you on stern
you know you took the time that you
needed to take you did what you needed
to do
you honored your children you were
faithful to your children as you sort of
put it
and it's different for everybody you
know and then of course kurt
raised me i'm he came into my life he
made me the man that i am
today he's taught me some really
amazing lessons um you know when i was
growing up
i was a mama's boy and my dad wasn't
there and i had
just my sister and my mother you know
kurt came into my life and i kept
hearing independent
and dependent these two words i knew
that being dependent was not a good
thing and
and being independent was sort of good
and freeing
i i didn't understand the meanings but i
understood the sentiment of it or the
feeling of it and i would hear that over
and over
we were in colorado we wrote atc's a
bunch
curt and i went down to the river about
a mile away and he just disappears at
the river and now i am
freaking out okay we call him paw
and i was like paw paw screaming my head
off
finally he comes around from behind a
tree and he was sitting there the whole
time waiting
letting me feel what i was feeling and
he said ollie ollie all right
relax calm down i'm right here i want
you to get us home
i'll be right behind you but you're
you're going to get us there and i was
resistant
finally agreed to do it looking behind
me the whole way
we get back to the place i get us home
and he says look if you were alone
you could get back you have to trust
yourself you have to believe in yourself
you have to know that you are capable
you're
you're just a capable boy and something
clicked
the next day i'm driving down the
driveway i'm alone on my atc my parents
are having coffee
and i say mom paw look i'm independent
not really understanding what that word
meant but just knowing
that it was a good thing and from that
moment on
things shifted for me as far as my
confidence and my self-esteem
you know i love this all so much
you